The daily sweep strategy changed my life
forever when I used it to break the
world record profit payout and made two
and a half million dollars. Before this,
I hopped from strategy to strategy, but
it's safe to say that this is the last
one I'll ever need. Today, I'm going to
teach you the full strategy so you two
can finally stick to one clear system
and become a profitable trader. Let's
hop right into step one. All right, step
one. So, while this is simple, if you
guys mess this up, then nothing else in
this system is going to work, so you
have to do exactly as I say. The first
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to mark out all of our hourly
swing points at 8:00 a.m. Now, I'm
typically trading the US equity open at
9:30, so obviously I want to be at the
charts an hour to an hour and a half
ahead of the open. So, at 8:00 a.m. I'll
sit down at my desk and I'll mark out
all of the previous hourly swing points
from the previous day leading up until
7:00 or 8:00 a.m. Now, if we're trading
beyond yesterday's price action, I just
want you guys to use the next most
recent day. And also, I want to point
out that I only want you guys to do this
on the hourly time frame. Not the
15-minute, not the daily, the 1-hour
chart because we're intraday trading and
we need a higher time frame to guide us
in our decision-making before even
looking at the lower time frames. So,
for this specific model, because it's
the daily sweep, it's an intraday model
and we need some type of higher time
frame indication of when we can start
hunting setups. So, for me, the hourly I
treat as my higher time frame. Now, we
are not going to go into the lower time
frames until we have the confirmations
that we're looking for. But first of
all, let's get into what an actual swing
point is. And it's very simple, a swing
low is a candle where both the candle
before it and after it have higher lows.
So, here on this example on the right,
we have this candle here that has a low,
we have a lower low, and then a higher
low. Now, once this third candle closes,
so each one of these candles is an hour,
once this third candle closes at the top
of the hour, this low down here becomes
our bullish swing point. Now,
opposingly, a swing high is a candle
where both the candle before it and
after it have lower highs. So, again, we
have a three candle pattern, we have
this candle here, which is candle one,
they have this high, the second candle
prints a higher high, and then the third
candle prints a lower high. Now, again,
we're waiting for a closure of the third
candle. So, at the top of this hour,
this high becomes our bearish swing
point. Now, why do these swing points
actually matter? So, they help us
identify when the market is creating
higher highs and higher lows, that means
the market's bullish. And if it's
creating lower highs and lower lows,
that means overall the market is
bearish. So, you can clearly see on this
example on the right, we have all of
these swing points as the market is
trending higher Now, yes, we do have
bearish swing points, but in an uptrend,
those bearish swing points will fail.
Now, there's also short-term runs on
these swing lows where we might have a
swing low, and then maybe we go raid the
low, and then create a new swing point
here before the market is allowed to
then trade higher. So, again, the market
doesn't move in a straight line. You
shouldn't expect it to. As traders,
we're just trying to make an educated
guess on which direction the market is
most likely to go. That doesn't mean
we're 100% certain on which direction
it's going to go. We're just trying to
make an educated guess, ideally a higher
probability guess, you know, maybe 60 to
70% of the time that we're getting this
correct in order to follow the higher
time frame trend. So, again, at 8:00
a.m. Eastern, I'm sitting down and I'm
plotting out all of the major hourly
swing points from the previous day.
Maybe I have to go back two or three
days if there's not enough data. So,
again, at 8:00 a.m., mark out all of
your major hourly swing points. Now,
that's step one. But, here's the thing,
and this is critical. These swing points
are about to reveal something that 99%
of retail traders never see, and that's
what we're going to discuss in step two.
But, first, let me tell you about
something important. This is the
strategy that I used to break the world
record with Apex. Now, if you guys want
an 80% discount on all evals, use code J
at checkout, and I'll leave a link down
in the description. All right, so, now
that you understand how to mark your
major swing points, let's tie this
together with this next concept. Because
without this one, step one, that won't
get you anywhere. Now, this is where we
go from having random lines on a chart
to having a crystal-clear trading
system. What we're going to talk about
next is swing failure patterns. Now,
what is a swing failure? It's when price
briefly breaks a significant swing high
or low, but quickly reverses, failing to
sustain the move and closing back within
the previous range. Now, this indicates
a potential trend reversal or liquidity
grab. So, as you guys can imagine, as
there's swing points being printed in
the marketplace, let's say we have this
bullish swing point. Guess where
everybody that's entering long is going
to put their stop loss. They're going to
put it below the swing low. And vice
versa, anybody that's trying to short is
going to short and put their stop loss
above this previous swing high. Now,
what is the swing failure pattern
though? Well, essentially what we're
looking for is this swing low to be
broken and then seeing a rejection going
the opposite direction. Now, as you guys
can see, both of these swing points have
been rated. So, this swing low, we
actually get a closure below it. And
this swing high doesn't close above it.
So, in the second example, this market
is actually weaker because it's
rejecting the high and not closing above
it. But, what do we actually wait for
for confirmation because these alone are
not swing failure patterns. What we're
actually looking for for a swing failure
pattern is a strong closure back into
the range. Now, this is where context
plays a part in the swing failure
patterns. If we raid out a high and then
this candle closes all the way down here
or bearish, that is much stronger than
where it's closing right now. And let's
say if we were bullish on this example,
well, we're not going to just try and
long as soon as it runs out this low.
We're going to wait for a nice bullish
closure back above this previous swing
low. Now, what is this actually telling
us? It's actually telling us that the
market wants to reverse and we're trying
to ride the coattails of smart money.
We're not trying to front run them. So,
again, why do they actually work?
Instead of trying to anticipate the
reversal, this provides confirmation
that it's actually happening. Now, I
have two examples to my right here of
how I used to learn turtle soups or
liquidity raids. So, essentially what I
learned was, okay, we have this swing
point, we have this liquidity pool.
After it's taken out, you're trying to
position below the low. Now, I lost
thousands of dollars and I wasted many,
many years trying to study this. Now,
this step and pattern that I'm talking
about will save you so much time and
energy and money. This is what my trades
used to look like. When we took out a
previous swing low, I would enter long
and then put my stop at a random point.
Now, so many times I would see that
trade drift a little bit lower, trigger
my stop loss, and then reverse. So, the
filter that I needed to add was this
swing failure pattern, which waited for
a confirmation after we get a closure
back inside of the range. Because the
problem with trying to pick the bottom
or pick the top is you don't really know
where to put your stop loss. As this
market is trading down here, there
really isn't much structure as it's
taking out this previous low. So,
instead, we're going to wait for the
closure and then place our positions.
Because these lows and highs that are
being printed should be protected
because they've already ran out
liquidity and we've got the confirmation
that the reversal is underway. Now, I
trade with a pretty big firm in Chicago
and my mentors are always telling me
that when you're trying to position
yourself in the market, you do not want
to be the first one that's rushing
through the door. Right? What do they
usually say about the first one that's
rushing through the door? They usually
get shot. And waiting for this
confirmation saved me so much money, it
saved me so much headache, and I was
actually able to position myself and
ride the coattails of smart money.
Because again, I'm not trying to be the
first person entering into a market. I
would rather catch the meat of a move
than try and top tick and bottom tick my
trades. So, now that you have the
general idea of how this works, let's
just run through price action and I can
show you guys a plethora of examples
where this actually pans out almost
every single day. So, if we just run
through our price action here, let's
just plot out some of our swing points
and see what we get. Now, when we're
trying to find entries on the lower time
frame, which I didn't even cover, okay,
what we're trying to find is a higher
time frame entry on the 1-hour, right?
We're waiting for a swing failure
pattern, and then you can use whatever
entry model you want on the lower time
frames. So, after we get the
confirmation, we're anticipating the
next couple hourly candles to print in
the direction that we're anticipating.
So, you can use a 5-minute chart, a
1-minute chart, a 15-minute chart. Find
your entry model and anticipate that
you're going to be in that move for a
couple of hours. All right, so what
we're looking for during these specific
trading times, and let's say we're going
to sit down at 7:00 or 8:00 a.m. This
candle closes at 8:00 a.m. And what do
we see here? We have a swing low, and
then we get a swing failure pattern. So,
what we're anticipating is the next
couple candles to print in the direction
that we're trying to go. So, this is a
bullish swing failure pattern because we
took out the swing low, and then we get
a nice closure. Now, as you guys can
see, on the next 2-hourly candles, this
market does trade higher and takes out
this swing high. And then later in the
day, if we're overall bullish, we can
see that this low is now protected. So,
again, if we were going to go long as
soon as this candle closed and put our
stop loss below the low. Now, I'm sure
if you go on a lower time frame, you can
really dial in a better entry. This
trade may go through a bit of drawdown,
but eventually it does trade higher.
Now, if you were only trading the hourly
and not dialing in your entry on the
lower time frame, this trade does
provide a 3R. Now, you can imagine if
you're trading on a lower time frame
like the 5-minute or the 15-minute,
maybe there's an opportunity to refine
your stop loss and your target and get
more than a 3R out of the specific
trade. All right, so let's fast forward
to the next day. Now, this was the day
before Thanksgiving, so what I'm going
to do is actually plot out this swing
high, but I'm not going to take any
trades on this Friday. This is Black
Friday. This is the day after
Thanksgiving, so we do have a gap in
data, which we do have this swing
failure pattern, but because there's no
overnight data, this makes things very
sketchy. And as you guys can see, if you
were trading this as a swing failure
pattern, this market just traded higher.
So, what we're going to do is skip to
the following day after that. Now, what
we're going to do is let's say if we're
bullish, we're going to plot out these
swing points from the prior day, and
what we're looking for is a nice closure
around our session open time above this
swing low. Okay, so overnight during the
London session, we actually get a swing
failure pattern, but because this is the
NASDAQ and most of the volume is coming
in around equity open and not during
London, we're going to skip ahead to New
York open here. Now, this New York open
candle actually has another SFP down
here because we have this swing low, and
then we get a nice closure above that
level. So, the following couple hourly
candles we're anticipating a run higher
after we get this SFP. And as you guys
can see, after we get the SFP, we have 1
2 3 4 hours that continuously push
higher. Now, again, the following day
we're looking for an SFP, and let's say
we're bullish again, we're looking for a
swing low to be rated to position
ourselves long. So, when we sit down in
front of our charts at 9:00 or 10:00
a.m., we're going to plot out our swing
points. Now, at 10:00 a.m. we got
another swing point here, but as you
guys can see, during New York equity
open, we don't run out any previous
swing points. So, maybe we're going to
avoid this trade entirely. And then the
PM session, we actually do get that SFP
during our trading hours, and then we
get a nice closure here. So, again, this
low should be protected. So, let's say
if we're to just go long and we're not
looking at a lower time frame, we're
going to go long and put our stop loss
below that low. And maybe we're just
going to target the high that's here.
All right, again, if you use a lower
time frame, there is probably an
opportunity in here on a 15-minute or
5-minute or 1-minute chart to have a
more refined stop loss. So, on Tuesday,
this provides roughly 2R, but again, if
you dial in on the lower time frame,
you're able to get a better risk to
reward with a tighter stop loss. This
setup does pan out in our favor. All
right, going to the next day, what we're
going to do at 8:00 a.m. All right, so
this candle closed at 8:00 a.m. We're
going to plot out our swing highs and
our swing lows. So, as you can see here,
we have two opportunities. In here, we
have a swing failure pattern right
before the New York open, but then it
just runs to this swing high, and then
it closes here. So, we have an SFP going
both ways. And really, this strategy
works in trending and ranging
environments. So, let's say right at
9:00 a.m. equity open, we've run out
this swing high. What are we
anticipating? We're anticipating
bearishness because it's failed to stay
above this high, and we get a nice
confirmed swing failure pattern on this
specific candle. As you can see, the
next hourly candle then prints lower.
Now, what happens if you completely
missed this move? Well, what I'm going
to do is plot out this swing low down
here, and we're going to wait for
another SFP because these are our swing
points, okay? If we're mainly just
trading swing failure patterns, we're
going to plot out our previous day's
swing points, so we have this swing low,
and we also have this swing low down
here. And we're going to wait for
another swing failure pattern. So, this
hourly candle, what does it do? We get a
closure below the swing point. And
again, what I used to do was I used to
go long as soon as we were waiting at
this level, not knowing really where to
put my stop loss. But what's going to
happen on the next candle is we get a
closure back above the low, which then
creates a swing failure pattern. Now, if
we drop down to our lower time frames,
yet again, there was likely an
opportunity to position yourself in
these following couple hourly candles to
then run out this previous swing high.
Now, fast forwarding through price,
let's say we come to this Friday. We
have this previous swing low. And then
what do we get? We get another swing
failure pattern. But see how this one
closes above the low? So, if we were to
drop down to a lower time frame, there's
probably an opportunity in here where we
can anticipate that this low is now
protected. Now guys, I could probably
spend hours and hours and hours sitting
with you and going through all of these
different swing failure pattern examples
and finding opportunity where if we get
a swing failure pattern, we can
anticipate at least two to three hourly
candles trading the opposite direction.
Now, I don't know how many examples I
have to show you, but as you can see, it
happens nearly every single day. On this
specific day, it's quite choppy. So, the
only swing point that I'm seeing right
now, leading up into the PM session, is
down here. And then we get the run
taking out this previous swing high.
Right? What happens after we take out
that previous swing high? We get another
SFP going the other direction. The
following day, what do we get here? We
have another swing failure pattern.
Right? We run out the high, we get the
closure, the next couple hourly candles
trade lower. Here we have another swing
failure pattern right at market open. We
get a nice closure here. Next couple
candles trade higher. Now, I want you
guys to do your homework. Go through
your charts. Do just as I say. Plot out
your hourly swing points. Look for swing
failure patterns. And see if the next
couple candles trade in the direction
that you're anticipating. Because once
you have these two pieces of
information, you could basically use any
entry model you want on the lower time
frame, and it should pan out. Now have
the same strategy that I used to make
millions of dollars and change my life
forever. But chances are you've probably
had profitable strategies before, but
still didn't become profitable. And I
get it because I failed for 10 years
before I was able to make it work. But
once I did, my life changed forever. So
please guys, whatever you do, just stay
consistent with this because trading
really can change your life if you have
the right system. I recently opened up
spots to my inner circle where I trade
with my students, give them my full
system, and coach them to become
successful traders and overcome the
hurdles that are keeping them stuck. Due
to this being a direct mentorship, I
only work with a limited number of
traders. If the link in the top of the
description works, then slots are open.
And if not, feel free to apply for the
next enrollment. As always, thanks guys
for watching, subscribe, and I'll see
you in the next video.